so meine damen und herren jetzt haben
wir die seltene gelegenheit mit einem
mann zutreffen der von putins krieg
direkt betroffen war er ist journalist
er ist chef vom radiosender echo moskau
gewesen der sender galt als letzter
unabhängiger sender und ist inzwischen
dicht gemacht worden
ja er ist bei uns maxime komiker 4 bei
uns im studio wir müssen gerade mit der
übersetzung so ein bisschen
improvisieren unser kollege dimitri
säumel der russisch spricht wird
übersetzen der kunde kauft können sie
uns den moment beschreiben als ihr
sender abgeschaltet wurde
[Musik]
rein und sagt da sagte
staatsanwaltschafts
trotzdem weitergemacht haben wir auf die
sendung vorbereitet und dann saß
und damit für thun im sinne
gesagt also mein lämpchen brennt ihr ich
glaube die haben uns ausgeschaltet
zuständig und da war mir klar dass wir
nur für moskau abgeschaltet worden waren
und deren die restlichen regionen wir
immer noch auf sendung und das ist
natürlich ein unvergesslicher moment
weil man kam sich vor wie kleine
untergehenden titanic
aller seien einige regionen haben dann
gesagt also wir uns seid ihr noch zu
hören
und dann
abgeschaltet wurden also
sondern
wurden wir nicht mehr gehört aber würden
weiter noch in youtube zu hören
und
einige tage bei youtube sind
unsere zuhörer haben natürlich dann 75
angehört wir viele waren das aber danach
wir dann gezwungen den youtube kanal
kann man dann sagen dass die sender
nicht mehr hatte ich weiß überhaupt
nicht ob es überhaupt noch einen live
signal aus moskau gibt wie war denn die
situation dann nachher für sie also sie
wurden abgeschaltet wussten die sie dann
sofort dass sie die jetzt gehen müssen
oder sind sie dann gegangen und sind
sofort nach deutschland gekommen was
kann auf die schiene studio oder das
was davon
wirklich
also ich sag mal so und chefredakteur
hat alle zusammen geholt und
dass diejenigen sehr gut verstehen
können die ausreisen wollen und auch
diejenigen die bleiben wollen er sagte
wir werden trotzdem auch über youtube
versuchen weiter zu senden das stück
funktioniert da noch in russland und wir
werden versuchen an unsere
journalistische funktion wahrzunehmen
es ist sehr schwierig weiterhin als zu
arbeiten während des krieges und nicht
zum aktivisten werden wenn krieg ist
dann verschwinden ja sehr viele dinge im
hintergrund aber die
sendungen die wir auf einem anderen
kanal
verbreiten konnten ihre zuschauer und
ist klar dass millionen von menschen
zehntausende von menschen in russland
die wahrheitsgemäße informationen haben
wollen und ihre eigene meinung bild sich
bilden wollen und nicht nur immer nur
das weitergeben was ihnen gesagt wird
wie gefährlich ist es für journalisten
die die wahrheit sagen wollen in
russland zu arbeiten
wenn sie den krieg als krieg bezeichnen
dann laufen sie gefahr dass ein
verfahren gegen sie eröffnet wird und er
können sie bis zu 15 oder gar 15 jahre
in den bau wandern das hängt davon ab
welche welcher straftatbestand dabei
gefunden wird und einige einige meiner
kollegen haben das schon am eigenen leib
erfahren die bereits abgeschalteten
wurden der sendung sich bereits
abgeschaltet wurden ein kollege nun
wurde ein verfahren eröffnet weil er den
krieg als das bezeichnet was er ist
nämlich als krieg wie sich so nennt wie
der kreml das überdies die stimmung im
land auch unter den menschen erst diese
stehen unglaublich viele menschen hinter
wladimir putin und dem was er tut aber
wir sehen auch immer mehr bilder von
demonstrationen menschen die auf die
straße gehen die für ihre freiheit
kämpfen und auch für das kämpfen dass
sie etwas sagen dürfen beschreiben sie
mal so ein bisschen die stimmung seit
wann sind sie jetzt hier und was haben
sie als sie dort waren noch mitbekommen
[Musik]
die demonstrieren gehen das sind
natürlich wahre helden und es ist klar
dass selbst wenn man den krieg nicht
unterstützt auf die straße zu gehen
natürlich eine heldentat
darstellt denn man kann jederzeit
verhaftet werden und deshalb gehen nur
sehr wenige menschen auf die straße
obwohl sehr viel mehr unzufriedene
natürlich im land existieren und es ist
ganz wichtig dass man
dieses nicht verwendet für diese sonder
für den sondereinsatz ich denke
vor dem hintergrund meiner erfahrungen
mit der russischen soziologie diese 25
prozent die offiziell genannt werden
tatsächlich diejenigen sind die gegen
den krieg auftreten der kern
und diejenigen die für den krieg sind
das sind vielleicht ein paar mehr 30 40
prozent wirklich denken und der rest ist
eine art
oder der versucht sich nicht dafür zu
interessieren und gingen zu finden die
wichtiger sind und dieser restliche zeit
wird natürlich immer geringer werden
leider
ist die propaganda in den ersten monaten
auf die fruchtbaren boden gefallen und
purple werden deswegen leider immer mehr
menschen zu denjenigen stoßen die den
krieg unterstützen sie haben nicht
genügend informationen um sich
vernünftig zu entscheiden aber je mehr
sich dann die situation zum schlecht mal
wenn nicht wirtschaftlich gesehen für
russland desto mehr menschen wird es
geben die sich dann auch dagegen
aussprechen aber leider ist die
atmosphäre
gegenwärtig in russland
die arbeit der staatlichen organe und
die propaganda zu kunst und des krieges
dass
menschen unter druck gesetzt werden
könnten wenn sie jetzt nach russland
fahren würden wären sie wahrscheinlich
schockiert von der scheinbar pro
kriegsrhetorik aber in wirklichkeit ist
es natürlich wenn die wenn sie sich für
den krieg aussprechen werden sie in eine
sackgasse geraten